what's going on reject nation we are at
cinemark as expected don't go to any
other theaters anymore ever and we just
saw
dune
part one which i know yes it's coming
out on hbo max but my god
i was watching this and
five minutes in i was thinking to myself
what kind of a fool would i be
if i watched this for the first time at
home
like a damn idiot so go to cinemark and
watch it here that is the kind of
branding they're looking for aggressive
aggressive they're gonna ask to use that
they're like hey can we make that a
couple of branded marketing
tv especially for your first time you
gotta watch it in the cinema and i
guarantee if you watch it at home you're
gonna be like i should have watched the
theaters
[Music]
hey guys i'm gonna say this spent hours
trying to fix it we had some major audio
issues all around and back up audio was
not that great either it bums me out so
much because you know as
much as i know that this will not be one
of our most viewed videos ever it's one
of my favorite discussions coming right
out of a movie we've ever done and put
on camera i think if you just like you
know sit back and settle in with the
audio it it'll be fine but i do
apologize for it not being up to par as
it has been with the previous just
watched videos
you'll see what i mean coy and john
sound better than me if you guys don't
know anything about dune i actually
forgot everything i ever learned about
dude prior to watching this movie i
don't know how to possibly just
summarize the plot of this really quick
i think the most efficient way to give
you an idea of the world you're diving
into directed by denis valeneu so you
know the kind of like tone and styles
that he tends to go for the best way i
can describe it is it's kind of like
star wars meets game of thrones that was
the most efficient way of like yeah i
would sort of see this movie not really
like space travel but planet travel what
it mainly deals with is you know the the
power of spice i'm trying to make it as
simplistic for you
a drug that heightens your senses and
spirituality but it's also the key to
space traffic yeah the thing that koi
would know a lot about and it's a really
heady sci-fi movie there's a it's very
thought-provoking wow
it's long it's like two hours and 45
minutes i was
engrossed in it from beginning to end i
love like the haunting menacing tone it
has it's very deliberate
uh ethereal and just the the tone it
just strikes you with from beginning to
end complimented by hanzim or score
is just so
beautiful i was like wrapped up in a
tortilla
of sci-fi cookies like that's the best
way i can explain it with just amazing
performances and probably the most
beautiful looking film i've seen all
year that's right i said most beautiful
film i've seen all year think of another
film that i might be comparing it to but
that's just my quick thoughts on it
before we go a little further john
please what do you think yeah i was
quite enthralled by this i mean denis
villeneuve's direction i feel like kind
of is the overarching star of the whole
thing because dune is billed as this
really hard to adapt piece and i'm not
an expert we actually watched it with
somebody who is a pretty big dune expert
but having gotten acquainted with it i
mean it i can see why this is always
built that way and i think he did a
stellar job in realizing the world the
feeling it's a true epic with sweeping
sets and costumes and this aura of you
know a larger than life interworking
network of religions and political
aspirations and all these different
things i thought yeah it was really
beautifully realized the cast for the
most part is great as the script
adaptation side of things goes that was
maybe the most lacking part for me
because a lot of stuff is pretty
streamlined and truncated and excised
and what not to make it work as a story
that fits into a movie but that being
said i thought this was a really uh
compelling first part to what i hope
becomes a complete
film adaptation that's fair that's fair
i mean for me i really felt like it's
one of those rare films where like it
feels like the most expensive passion
project i've ever seen
it really does koi what did you think so
when i look at sci-fi films denny stands
out a lot blade runner 2049 is one of my
favorite modern sci-fi films but i think
it's really important when you have
genres like this where you've got the
town is a cop drama like pizza cop drama
but you've also got like your marky mark
denzel faire that's going to be a little
bit more streamlined a little bit more
mainstream not to completely make little
of those things but they're different
feels and to me star wars is going to be
your more streamlined mainstream sci-fi
whereas this is going to be your
godfather versus star wars scarface like
you've got different paces different
feels different atmospheres different
ambiances this isn't something you throw
on casually this is something you
immerse yourself in you wrap yourself up
in this is something that is an event it
is an experience which is why i watched
it at center mark the whole thing feels
like you need to be immersed in it
completely i loved all of that i love
the politics of it i love the tribalism
of it i love the colonization of it i
love the commentary on our world as an
aggressive pollution and advocate i love
that we're discussing it as an
enhancement instead of a hindrance if
you look at the way human beings have
evolved we've actually advanced our
culture quite a bit through
hallucinogens so looking at the
larger scale of perhaps using that for
things that expand our world to the
cosmos it's a really cool adjustment to
look at a movie like this that's
adjusting sci-fi to have that effect on
reality so it meant a lot to me that the
spice was this having known very little
about it and i think the whole thing
felt like what i want sci-fi to always
feel like and the cast is one of the
sexiest casts ever assembled so it's
very beautiful to look at aesthetically
and as a human being appreciating human
beings we took shrooms before watching
this can you tell oh wow the screen was
just popping i feel it they're just
popping at us the whole time you guys
taste that purple
[Laughter]
spice
i can travel the cosmos
one thing i'll say too that i i was i'm
not surprised by just because denise
villanue's like one of my favorite
directors it's that how physical
everything felt yeah to watch a sci-fi
movie where everything just feels very
tangible like yes are there some sci-fi
sets like like cgi-wise totally um but a
lot of times i couldn't even tell like
exactly what was cgi and what was
practical other times it's more apparent
but especially when you're in like you
know dealing with the sand and watching
the actors having to go through this the
whole environment the sweat the
scuzziness it made that much more
beautiful the ickier it actually got i
would say yeah and there's some pretty
cool action here it's not like
action-packed but when there is action
it is gripping there are some real tense
moments for sure throughout and and with
the cast too i think they're all i think
i feel like everyone was pretty much
perfectly cast
i know some people here have a
slightly different opinion about it i
think he was perfectly cast it's okay i
do think he was perfectly
lately i was thinking i was sitting
there going chalamet is the perfect
casting for this the guy who read the
book this guy the guy well he's got the
pages
this was a silent film best silent film
of the year the score we should talk
about we're talking about sound han
zimmer did not just do that one thing he
does now it was more there were many
songs
the sound design was so immersive like
we were talking about the visuals being
almost like jurassic park which is the
highest praise i can give a movie where
you blend the cgi with the practical why
not and now this in sci-fi scale but
also that the sound design does
something similar it immerses you into
it in a very aggressive way to quote
everyone's review of eternals it's a
very intense material
but it's weirdly not as slow was i
expected it to be i will admit the first
20 minutes i was worried uh because i am
an american a.d.d riddled like what
cinema but once i was in i was so in and
i think it really took a couple minutes
for me to adjust my
inner clock but once i was there i think
it's such an immersive film i think the
cast is just so great in here i mean for
me i'm wondering like who my favorite
performer is
um
oh god that's so hard rebecca let's just
go up here first rebecca ferguson
hottest mom in the world yeah and you
could tell at times timothy chalamet was
even like man why should i be my mom
i think that was the line he said at one
point yeah
i talked about
explicit
subjects i love the always seen the
stealing david desmond uh the dude's got
so much presence when he arrives and
you're always like this guy you want to
know more about him i thought josh
brolin who dude was very limited in the
trailers he does so much more here he's
such like an empowering force in this
movie you feel the energy just come back
i think it was one of his scenes early
on in the movie where i'm like oh i'm
really emotionally pulled in now because
of a very specific speech he gives early
on and that's when i was like hooked
and uh josh brolin was like it's a
powerhouse in the spirit and his
relationship with oscar isaac was great
i bought everything
yeah but i bought their connection and i
you need to for each of their characters
to work you need to believe in this
hierarchy you need to believe in the
structure you need to believe in this
world of this i don't know this
political intrigue and if you don't
you're out so you need brolin and oscar
to really have this immediate connection
that works in this film was that one guy
javier bardem or was i only thinking
it was
yes
because he was great because i didn't
recognize the guy when he showed up yeah
and then he started speaking i'm like
that dude sounds like hobby or birthday
is it jeffrey dean morgan like a quarter
i never know i recognized david dawson
the second i said oh yeah put off here
my damn i was like
[Music]
[Laughter]
i mean she's so
enigmatic and and everything about her
you want to be pulled into that story
and you're so in a dream state with her
and you want to know more about her and
it's perfectly cast because of insender
like you tell me more about you and
that's well handled because i mean a lot
of hers her actual action
takes place later and i thought they
made her presence still feel very
plugged into this movie even though a
lot of what she has to really do isn't
quite arrived yet in the story yeah i
mean by the time that you know like
where the inevitable
encounter
with timothy chalamet and her happens it
feels a little rewarding
yeah there's a spoilers there's an
element they meet
stalin stars
stella skarsgard oh my god how do we not
talk about the amazing makeup in this
movie the makeup was phenomenal here
that's another part that made it feel so
lived it maybe they're part you know i
know that dune is a big part of what
inspired star wars and it is kind of
neat to watch it in sort of that meta
lens yeah when you're like oh you can
see the star wars shades here and
it doesn't ever seem like it's borrowing
from what it begat in helping star wars
to become what it was like it really
does feel like no it's its own thing but
you can really see the lineage yeah i
thought it was great i think it's one of
the best movies i've seen all year
undoubtedly out of five koi what would
you give it i give this a solid four
four out of five i i've only given
sixteen five out of fives my entire life
so to scale four is very high uh the
stoned ape theory meets politics meets
space opera and it's the scope i wanted
dune to be and i feel like because of
this movie i understand the doom culture
in a way that i didn't really grasp
before being outside of it what would
you rate me
ten that five that's what i'm talking
about [ __ ] easy look out now
yes
i'd give it probably a
a four probably around a four wow maybe
a three point seven for every one today
what do you got i'm a four point two
five this guy's an extra quarter because
of timothy shalvay who we did not touch
on to protect someone from the comment
boxes
it's only if it's fine guys i thought he
was fine he's good he was just the only
character who didn't have as much
presence to me as literally any other
character of course but he's the special
so it makes sense don't you feel like in
movies like with this ensemble it's
usually the lead who surprisingly is the
least absolute
which is why
it's like a phenomenon where you get to
know the lead so much more you expect
inherently more out of them like your
best friend you always assume more out
of so is it the lead being so much
screen time that you're like why whereas
you got someone they have to do so much
more work if they've got five pages they
need to deliver 100 pages worth of
impact so maybe something that is 100
pages you just don't feel that impact
because it's so much more ongoing it's
like a spice you get sat right away you
remember that instead of like a nice
rolling buffalo i don't know i found
myself like there are moments in the
finale what the circumstances are dealt
his way where i do find myself like
rooting for him quite a bit and i agree
i felt like a lot of that fell on
timothy chalamet to get me to care about
him when a character in his position who
has these special gifts who has like
chosen one sort of
that makes and it's really hard for me
to actually root for people like that
and for here i was like
yo i'm really hoping this guy nails all
those qualities down they're supposed to
name it yeah yeah i usually struggle
with the chosen one yeah all right guys
well thank you so much for being here
cinemark thank you guys so much for
rooking this up wow what uh that this is
like this
this is this is cinema
cinemark this is cinnamon cinnamon
if you can't spell cinemark without
cinema i'm gonna go get some spice
deodorant and hallucinate
you